我是来自英语技术部密码团队的张磊
今天的主要内容,主要包括四部分
SPU实现PSI的介绍
SPUPSI的调路架骨
SWIPRO的PSI开发指南
以及第四部分PSI的后续计划
首先我们来介绍SPU实现的PSI的介绍
这部分就包括SPU已经实现的PSI的种类和一些级别性质
首先我们来介绍一下PSI的定义和种类
PSI是安全求交集的语言缩写
它是一种特殊的安全多方计算协议
就是IS持有集合X,BOB持有集合Y
IS和BOB通过这些协议得到交集X交外
在协议就是出交集外,不过也洩漏交集外的其他信息
关于PSI的一些基础理论
可以看我们的第一期
穆克第一期的内容
PSI的分类主要是
按参与方可以分为两方和多方PSI
按两方数据级的差异可以分成Balance和UnbalancePSI
按安全模型可以分为半程式和恶意PSI
还有一些代计算的PSI类型
包括PSI的交集数量
以及PSI的Payload分析
还有SocketPSI
我们来介绍言语PSI的功能分层
言语PSI的协议实现主要是在中间的SBO层
在这一层就包含了我们不同类型的PSI的协议实现
它的底层是基础组建层
压扣就包括了一些基础的密码算法和一些基础的密码协议
包括像ECCA,IS,HACI,OT,OPF,PRG
还有我们需要用到的网络连接的link
在SBO网上就是包装了一个Bucky的统一的PSI的入口
通过这个入口可以屏蔽调不同协议的差异
调用的时候我们就是要指定相关的输入和基础类型就可以调用PSI
然后再往SBO上层的就是Secret Flow是我们的一个Python的调用框架
在这一层的PSI包含了PSI的CSV和PSI的DF
两个函数分别是指的
它的输入是CSVn件和DataFrame
再往上层就包含了我们的MVPE和CUSHA
也就是我们的最小功能实现
这一部分就包含了白屏OpenAPI和调度功能
像右侧还包括了circle
包括通过一些circle的语句来执行一些PSI和安全多方计算的内容
circle它是目前是直接调用SPU的CIA加的接口
没有通过Secret Flow这一层
我们下面介绍了SPU实现的PSI的种类
目前主要是以半程式为主
半程式就包括了多方
像多方包含了ECDH
两方包含了ECDH,KRT,BCR
包括UnbalancedPSI和DPPSI
多方就给予ECDH的一个三方计算
这样恶意模型实现了一个miniPSI
适合于两方交集数量不太大的一个小数字计
关于PSI的详细介绍可以参考官网上的文档
文档上基本上包含了协议的介绍和一些性能的数据
我们看右侧
大体可以看作是PSI的一个发展趋势
从最早的继续供药的一些PSI的类型
发展到16年KRT OT
JOT和OTE的这种PSI的一些
在网上像R2年的BCR和BlesinFastPSI
大体性能也是逐渐提升的
首先我们介绍SPO中实现的ECDH
ECDHPSI跟它相对协议比较简单
然后应于理解
以言于实现
它的同性量相对比较小
然后计算量相对比较大
予以扩展到像
求交集数量
还有一些计算的类型的PSI类型
所以在大部分的安全协议的实现
都会实现基于ECDHPSI
它的协议的主要的过程
主要是第一步
像Alice这段
她自己的数据通过一个哈希哈希
到一个ECDHPSI的点
然后通过一个私药
对这些点进行加密
做一个典成
然后发送给Bob
Bob这一段
他对自己的外的数据同样也做一个典成
同时对接收到的Alice这段的数据
用她的私药β再做一次典成计算
然后Alice这段
计算外的α磁方
然后得到
就是x的αβ磁方和y的
两个金河的αβ磁方
然后计算交集
因于SPUECDHPSI的协议实现
主要是有三个特点
一个是性能方面的
提升
支持了2529FQU曲线
还有增加了
给予intel对一个AVX-V2
这种处理器的
上队MatiBuffer的支持
第二个就是侧柄和合规的需求
还是增加了像SMR曲线和256K1曲线的支持
另外就是互联互通
现在就是
GECDH的互联互通协议
也相当于完成了相关的标准
和目前也有很多家
都完成了相关的互联互通的测试
关于GECDHQ2的文档和倉务实现
可以参考研议的官网给他
那我们看一下
ECDHPSI的性能
目前在性能最快的是
像在intel
intel第三代处理器上
我们一个2.24尺方的数据
其他的时间大概是在32秒
FQU曲线
它大概是在60多秒
像2519这种200处理器的intel处理器的机器上需要140多秒
那我们一个参考基础可以看看KRT
它的2.24尺方大概是在一分钟左右
那么介绍英语实现的第二个
PSI的第二个协议就是PKRT
PKRT这一篇文章是比较重要的一个
PSI协议
它主要是扩展了
这个OT贪婶
并且基于这个OT贪婶构造了一个
Batch related OPRF
它的特点就是预计时间表夸
然后像百万在3.8秒
然后1.6千万的数据期
也就是2.24尺
大概在一分钟
目前的像6年之后的很多PSI的
协议大同文实义和PKRT做一个比较的基准
PKRT它的缺点就是内存占用量比较大
通信量比较大
我们看右侧这个是跟RT协议的主要流程
它的主要构建的就包括了库戈哈希
以及刚才提到了OT贪婶和OPRF
简单介绍一下库戈哈希
它只基于多个哈希
比方说这个例子里面就是以三个哈希为例
三个哈希之左侧就是对X做三个哈希
然后判断从哈希没有H1 X1
它的位置有没有数据
如果是空的这么放到H1的位置
如果H2的位置是
H1被占用的就放到H2
H2被占用的就放在H3的位置
如果全部被占用的话
会随即找一个被占用的地方
然后把它这个数据
比方说它的占用的数据是X2
把它替换到X2的其他的index上
我们的PKRT实现的也是做了一些性能上的优化
这块主要是列了三个
一个是对其中计算量比较大的矩阵转质
还有用的比较多的EIS和这个库哈希
做了一些性能优化
下面是左下角是一个性能的数据
像PKRT论文里面列的时间是在58.6秒
Libre PSI这个代码库测的是在48.7秒
SPU的PKRT性能大概是在44.3秒
然后首先介绍一下库哈希
目前用的是大概是PSC-18和PSC-19里面
提到了一个叫Stash-free的方案
这个转是指的是在原始论文里面
向库哈希它的哈希的方案里面
如果是两个哈希可能会再插入的森巴哈希
会有冲突
这个时候就需要构建一个Stash
Stash大体就是一个冲突器
这个冲突器它的计算复杂度相对比较高
因为如果是正常的森巴哈希的位置
它是比较并这个位置的数量
然后Stash哈希这个位置
它是要和外地方缩的数据做比较
那么看下面两个性能优化
一个是Type AS和Vector AS
Type AS主要是把AS算法的内部的一个
时轮的一个计算过程拆解
拆解以后
就是比方说我们要对四个数据做AS
那我们先对四个数据做它的第一轮
然后再做四个数据的第二轮
最后再做第十轮
这样我们同时完成四个数据的AS
相对每个数据完成十轮之后
再去执行下一个数据这个性能也会有所提升
另外一个Vector AS是利用InterCPU的一个指令
它也是一次可以加密两到四个数据
然后下面第三个优化是矩阵转质
矩阵转质包括了两种类型的优化
一种是纯算法性方面的
是基于一个叫Oak London的这个算法
下面是基于Intel的一个比特转换的一个矩阵转质
这种Intel的比特转换指令就是
将若干个字节的数据的
比方说第一个比特继续出来
就可以加速这个矩阵的转据运算
下面介绍实现的BCL2的协议
BCL2它是全程可以看到下面两篇论文
我们在二年实现的时候
它是2030-14这个版本
然后在2023年它们又更新了一个文档
并且是发表在PCR023的这个会议上
PCR023主要是基于Subfield VLE
构建了一个BRKU-PRF
以及另外一个就是用了一个Generate的枯克哈奇
第三点就是用了一个
基于Permutation的一个哈奇
首先介绍一下Generate的枯克哈奇
首先在KRT那边可以看到
左侧的这个Subfield哈奇
它的每一行大概只有一个元素
如果有冲突的话
它会放到哈奇的第二个位置
或者第三个位置
在Generate的枯克哈奇里面
它把每一行元素增加到两或者三个
这样的话就是在哈奇比较少的情况下
比方说两个哈奇的情况下
也可以做到Stash Free的这种比较好的特点
右侧是BCL2的一个协议流程
首先它记住BRKU-PRF的方案
构建这个
若干数量的BRKU-PRF
这个BRKU-PRF的数量需要根据我们
枯克哈奇的数量
以及枯克哈奇的每一行的元素
来计算出枯克哈奇的枯克哈奇的数量
然后同时我们其实可以插入枯克哈奇
和右侧的森巴哈奇
然后再构建一个BRKU-PRF
然后双方交互UPRF的值
然后再做测计算出这个交集
我们介绍一下选用的
在实现的时候选用的参数
像架边尔的枯克哈奇的参数大概是三二
每一行大概有三个元素
哈奇的数量是两个
VR E的目前使用的是MTCK里边的
而一年的这个UPRF的方案
实现的观众和论文的一个差异
就是左担的差值多样是论文
给出了不做停充的方案
目前我们是做的都是要做停充
比如说就说森巴哈奇是三个元素
如果不到三个元素我们停充一个随机制
论文中不做停充的好处呢
它有两个就是它的特点就是
优点就是降低计算量
缺点就是需要额外的一个
F2上的一个SUBFU的VR E
然后右侧的时候我们看到这个性能的对比
那在通信量和计算量方面
BZ2和RZ2R这两篇据
这种PCG或者VR E的这种PSI的
它的性能包括通信量和计算量
其实都是相对比较好的
咱们介绍一下这个Ambalance PSI
在我们实际的应用过程中
可能会出现两方数据级的
数量级差距比较大
比如说一方是10亿或者是20亿
然后另一方大概是百万或者是千万这个级别
然后这个时候如果用普通的ECDH
它也可以做
但是相对来说这个就算开销就会比较大
那我们去于这种团区线上的OPR F
构造这种Ambalance PSI
可以相对级减少计算量
我们看一下这个OPR F
OPR F它的大级原理
就是说发送方这边发送这个级的
比方说二字方到封端
然后封端它计算一个级的s字方
然后呢
扣端收到之后再计算一个级的二逆
这样就可以得到级的s字方
在我们这例子里面
就是lx计算二二字方
然后β计算x的β字方
然后s收到之后再计算一个β逆
这样就得到了hx的β字方
然后和发过来的hy的β字方做比较
可以得到交集
和普通的ECD一直相比较
它的计算量相对比较小
像ECD第一尺它的计算量是两倍的
比方说ny是一个大数学
需要两倍的ny
那在ECD OPR F这个计算量
ny这块只需要计算一次
所以性能我们就会差距比较大
右侧是我们的一个时间的一个对比
那么看到大体
cd opr f
可能变一次电影池
大概要提升一倍
它的主要的提升的点
就是刚才我们看到的计算量
对于ny大数学计算的计算量
减少了一把
然后下面我们介绍
基于sumwater同态的psi法
这个主要是
基于labelpsi的法
目前微軟在github发了
这颗labelpsi的参考实现
一psi
我们也是基于这个psi的
做了一些封装
它这个行业的特点就是
不需要把大数学计
发送到对方
对服务端会对它的数学计
做一个差距多样式
然后客户端把它的查询的数据
然后同台秘论发到服务端
服务端计算这个多样式的结果
反反还给客户端
客户端这个多样式
如果紧密
紧密失灵
那表示x在y的集合里面
如果紧密不失灵
它得到的是一个随意数
就表示x不在服务端的数据里面
这里的优点就是
不需要将大量大数据方的数据
传输到小数据方
然后缺点就是
计算量会比较大
运行时间会比较长
下面介绍一个
基于ecdh的三方psi
这个协议是内部自己设计的
然后它的协议特点就是
基于ecdh
然后方向就比较简单
当然也有一些不好的点
可能就是会泄露xbub的交集数来
当这个协议交互流程里面
就是lxbub先执行一个普通的ecdh协议
不同的点就是说
这里对比方说x发过来的集合
也要做一个shuffle
这样x这端它就只能得到这个交集
但是交集没法和x自身的数据
就是做一个对应
lx这端把两方交集发送给第三方Charlie
Charlie这块他会做
他对两方交集做一个gambas方
同时lx把自己的数据hzgambas方发送给bub
然后bub计算它的beta四方
然后再发给sx72八次方
最后我们得到一个hz的fb四方
以及sxbub的fb四方
可以得到一个三方的结果
psi的实现位置
在spu的代码库里面
大家可以看到是在利波spupsi目录下
然后核心的代码实现是在靠目录下
然后对一些外部的依赖
可以添加在这个像压扣的一些依赖里边
还有spu的依赖像mg2和microsoft的psi
代码测试呢
就是主要针对每一个变财实现
对于相对的代码测试
第二部分我们介绍spu的调度风状
spu的调度架构呢
主要目前可以看到
sqlflow这一层有psi的sv
然后通过spu的8k的psi
8k的psi主要是通过一个分统调度
还解决一个大数据的问题
然后再去调度对每个分统调度具体的psi协议
像我们以千万为力
这里列到了是百万将千万分成十个百万
然后百万百万求交之后呢
对结果进行一个合并
这个下面就是我们调问家后的一个结果风状层
这个主要是在
能看到分成了8k的psi
mammarpsi和operator
我们通过operator将不同的协议
注册到mammarpsi
然后统一有8k的psi做调度
8k的psi它的page就包括了
调用的时候的一个传输参数
就是psi的一个page
包括psi的类型
resever的一个rack是否广播结果
输出参数把输出的路径和ID
输出的路径和曲线类型
以及这个分统的大小
像默认分统就是100万
那么看到这个8kpsi的调用的时候
就是需要传一个psi的configure和一个link
然后如果需要互联互通的话
可以把这个smodu稍微处
mammarpsi的它的相对来说
就更它的page就更简单
它只需要一个协议类型
接收方的一个一个标识
是否广播以及这个协议类型
operator这个主要是用于在协议注册的8kpsi
如果有兴趣的同学
可以添加新的协议
也可以通过operator注册
那么下面列了一个operator的这个
一个实例
主要是像krt它的实现这个on run的这个函数
同时通过一个注册函数
把krt注册到我们的operator
那我们下面来介绍
这个batch provider
batch provider是读取sfsv文件的一个借口
它主要是有两种实现
一种是基于这个memory的
一种是基于sfsv文件的
主要是通过指定每次读取的数量
分批读取这个数据
下面介绍一下它的开发者
开发者主要是
主要是被psi的一个调度的一个介绍
像psi的目前的passing结构
结构主要是通过银语来sqrt flow的结构来调度
sqrt flow目前的部署方式主要有两种
一种是仿真极其仿真模式
一种是生产模式
在极其仿真模式下
我们有一个主的节点
然后将调度任务发给主的节点
由主的节点来调度
从节点来执行材材的交互
生产节点需要两方同时执行
具体的银语的部署模式
我们也有相近的课程
然后大家也可以参考官网的这个安装和部署的文档
在调用的主要过程中
第一步就是先启动锐议集群
然后第二步就是初始化sqrt flow
sqrt flow的page主要是各方的地址和坚定端口
我们这里也是以生产模式为例
还有trs的page
包括这些证出我们要
然后使用spu的设备
这里主要是指定spu的link的坚定端口
然后执行psi
这里主要是page PSI CSV的一些参数
像我们输入的路径
还有我们的CSV的ID列
输出协议类型
还有对输入和输出的
是否输入是否检查
对输出是否排序
后面我们介绍银语的后续计划
银语的后续计划主要是分成三块
第一块就是新协议的开发
像我们这次Bless & Fast
GVLE Hocus PSI
像Zonkey PSI
多方PSI 以及恶意PSI
目前多方PSI
作为一个YSP的工件任务发布在社区
现在有开发同学
外部的开发同学接受了我们多方PSI的任务
欢迎更多的同学来参与到我们的PSI开发
第二块就是我们电源框架
电源框架这块
刚才介绍了PSI目前转入在spu的代把库
后续可能会
因为spu本身还包括一些安全多方计算的功能
所以PSI这块
像后续可能会单独一个代把库
这样的会对如果PSI有独立需求的
它的依赖就不会那么大
然后第二个就是优化优化函数和参数
第三个是优化协议的封装架构
第三大块就是PSI的产品
这包括PSI的轻量和部数
还有上版原理的一些可实化